hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are going back into the world
of for tonight Battle Royale but this
time we are looking at all the Easter
eggs TV and film references and even a
few memes we found in each season
today's episode is all about season 1
which ran from September the 17th 2017
through to December the 13th so if
you're ready let's do this I'll start
with my personal favorite nod to pop
culture which you walk past every time
you play take a moment to look at the
milk cartons around the settlement on
the island and if you're a fan of
Britpop band blur you'll see a reference
to their music video copy and TV from
back in 1999 ok so I'm sure you've seen
the robot made from cars over on the
east side of the island
most people say this is a reference to
Optimus Prime and the Transformers well
I don't believe that's the case instead
I think this is a nod to the Simpsons
and truckasaurus
which fits the size perfectly and the
overall scale matches to what do you
reckon is this an old man Optimus Prime
or an elderly truckasaurus by the time
season 2 started there were loads of
posters around the island but back in
season 1 one poster was always present
this pixelated masterpiece found above
many beds in the game is from epic games
previous game series Unreal Tournament
and the facing world's level this is
another 1990s reference but others go
even further back than that on the edge
of the map above lonely Lodge is a
secret golden chest atop of a vehicle
about to fall from the cliff well back
in 1969 a film entitled The Italian Job
was released it was a bank heist movie
which spoiler alert ends with the
criminals being stuck in a bus on the
edge of a cliff do they try and get the
gold or do they save their own lives the
film ends immediately without resolving
this problem but it hops back to the
risk reward of trying to get the gold
even though it's a huge threat to your
life so be honest have you grabbed this
chest and fallen to your death cosmetic
items began to be introduced during
season
the lucky act popped up with a smiley
face adorned upon it
the origins of the face go back to the
1950s but any self-respecting geek will
recognize the design from the watchman a
superhero bunch depicted in both graphic
novel and on the silver screen - it even
had Megan from the walking dead in it
but we'll get to that Easter Egg when we
get to season three here's a strange one
over in the shipping containers are a
buttload of metal resources to claim if
you spend long enough here you will
stumble across this strange suitcase it
can't be destroyed but on closer
inspection things get extra weird inside
the suitcase is a conveyor belt with
cabbages and other items found around
the world I honestly can't figure out
what this could mean but I have a
sneaking suspicion it's a nod to the PVE
save the world mode and maybe a solution
to that zombie issue oh there's another
save the world reference which could
only be found during season one the TV
sets around the island could be
interacted with and a weird dancing
alien appears for a few seconds well
that little troll can be found in the
PvE mode and regularly steals blue glow
from the players he also appears in
limited time events such as beneath a
frozen lake at Christmas time there's a
battle royale phenomenon which began in
season 1 when a mysterious gnome could
be found in a wall structure this is a
completely random event which has a
small chance of happening when a brick
wall is built in the game so I've been
playing for hundreds upon hundreds of
hours and I've only seen one two three
times so to say it's rare is an
understatement
have you been lucky enough to see one of
these ugly little buggers in one of your
structures and the final Easter egg in
season 1 was the original dance emote we
all started with known as the dance
moves it's actually taken from the
medical comedy scrubs and the scene
where Turk struts his funky stuff so
that's what happened back in season 1
next episode we'll be looking at season
2 and the influx of Easter eggs and
references found there I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade I'll see you very
soon
[Music]
you